okay so the super-fit so let me write
down the super clip for you
Rubik's Cube fans have a notation and
they call this the up they call this the
down they call this the right hand side
or for obvious reasons the left hand
side the front which is facing me and
the back which is facing away from me
there so it's got up down left right
front and back I can write down the
super flip using this idea it's going to
take 20 moves I'm going to write down
what the 20 moves are then we'll try it
out looks like this up so I'm going to
turn the up once now this means vikon
side twice once twice front that's
taught me once back that's over here
it's the back right right hand side
again back twice I'll get it there
1 2 3 right up twice one two left back
twice 1 2 right you - that means the
opposite direction anti-clockwise down
anti-clockwise right-hand side twice
front right-hand side backwards left
bottom twice once twice up twice once
twice and then do the front twice so
once twice look at that so there are 20
moves there and this was super flip the
key form the sold state you get this
really pretty combination there and this
is the farthest away from being solved
that you can get now if you look at it
what's happened is all the corners are
perfect if I see this is the orange face
all the orange corners and the center
are just fine this is the orange face
look at the edge pieces this is the
orange white edge and it's
flipped over turn it round this is the
orange blue edge and it's flipped over
this is the orange yellow edge which is
flipped over and that's the orange green
edge and that's flipped over so all the
edge pieces flip over all the corners
are absolutely fine and the center's are
always fine they don't move at all
there's a couple of cool things about
this super flip that I haven't told you
yet so if I do the super flip twice so
the super flip was 20 moves if I do it
twice I will get back to where I started
saying mathematics we say it has order
two you do it twice and you'll get back
to where you started so that's pretty
cool
the other cool thing about the super
flip is that if I do a bunch of moves
and then I do the super flip you'll get
the same answer as if you do the super
flip first and then you do that bunch of
moves so you'll get the same answer so
if you do super flip first and stuff or
if you do stuff first and super flip
you'll get the exact same position and
that's in fact the super flip is the
only move that isn't just doing nothing
at all it's the only move that has that
property close I thought that would be
true for everything but it's not it's
not true for everything now this is just
really important so if I do and move
followed by another movie the order
matters the order matters you get a
different answer if you do it in a
different order if you to swap those
over except for the super flip only the
super flip this doesn't this this works
the order doesn't matter
Oh lock up know what man